la force est dans la beauté la beauté
est dans la force qu'est-ce qui vous
rend belle Miss Hulk partit Tania c'est
bien la personne qui légalement a été
plus maligne que toi
pourquoi tu n'as pas déposé ton pseudo
pourquoi faire
parce que Docteur Strange a eu à déposé
son nom ou tort tu as pris en exemple de
personne qui utilise leur véritable nom
je suis toujours Jennifer Walter c'est
involontairement que je suis devenu
missile t'aimais pas qu'on t'appelle
Miss Hulk exactement c'est ça cela dit
il y a des aspects que j'apprécie ça je
le reconnais
[Musique]
le soir sans avoir peur
peut-être le moment d'enfiler votre
costume si vous changez en géante je
sais pas comment vous appelez ça
d'accord
des problèmes bizarres et inattendus
pourquoi vous ne répondez pas au
téléphone je reviens la vie serait
tellement plus facile si j'étais
simplement gêne vous êtes dans une
position unique pour faire de bonnes
choses gene Walters fut utilisé la loi
pour aider les personnes à qui la
société fait défaut Miss Hulk peut aider
les personnes qui la loi avait défauts
[Musique]
déjà parce que tu as envoyé des textos
au volant dis-leur que c'était adressé
au service d'urgence ils pourront pas de
poursuivre il ne s'agit pas de ça et
c'est un mensonge